أحد الأسئلة التي أطرحها دائمًا عندما
أذهب إلى طبيب الأسنان ، ربما تكون
قد قمت بتنظيف أسنانك بالخيط بما يكفي مثل
العديد من الأشخاص هناك ، أشعر
بالحرج قليلاً لأقول إنني لا أفعل ذلك بشكل
كافٍ ولكن يجب أن أفعل ذلك.  أعلم أنه
يجب أن تكون أسنانك بمثابة نافذة
على روحك الصحية إذا كان
لديك التهاب في لثتك ، فمن
المحتمل أن تصاب بالتهاب في
أجزاء أخرى من جسمك ونعلم
أن الالتهاب هو أكبر
مؤشر على الأشخاص المصابين  سوف
تصاب بأمراض القلب في وقت لاحق ، لذا فكر في
أن تنظيف أسنانك بالخيط
يقلل من خطر الإصابة بأمراض القلب ،
فمن كان يعتقد أنك بحاجة إلى
جعل هذا الأمر بسيطًا قدر الإمكان ، اجعل
تنظيف الأسنان بالخيط أولوية ، كلما قمت بتنظيف أسنانك بالفرشاة ، إليك القليل
نصيحة يجب عليك تنظيف أسنانك بالخيط قبل تنظيف
أسنانك ، فأنت تريد إزالة كل تلك
البلاك ثم تنظيفها بعيدًا إذا
فعلت ذلك ، فأنت لا تساعد
فمك فقط ، فأنت لا تساعد فقط في منح
نفسك ابتسامة جميلة.  ه
مساعدة بقية جسمك وكذلك
هذه طريقة جيدة للعيش حتى 100